Cecily I'd like for you to just close  this out by giving everyone watching the  impression that you hope they leave with  I really think there's a strong  connection between how we see ourselves  how women are portrayed in films and how  they're thought of in society you know  women are not things women should have  agency women's bodies belong to  themselves we need to really look at our  culture and see where some of this might  have come in on a subconscious level and  I think there's a connection here and I  just I'd like to plant that idea that  this is something that goes beyond film  and as filmmakers  especially here in Hollywood to think  about what we're putting out in the  world and how that is affecting the  world that we live in for ourselves and  for our children